الجيش الاوكراني قال ان الدفاعات الجويه
اعترضت خمسه عشره مسيره مفخخه اطلقها
الروس باتجاه مقاطعه دنيبرو جنوب الشرقي
الجيش الاوكراني ان قوته خاضت 30 اشتباكا
مسلحا على جبهات القتال كافه في الساعه
الاربعه والعشرين واكد انه سيواصل هجماته
في اقليم دومباس
انه لا يزال مستمرا في هجومه المعاكس
باتجاه مولوتوبول حيث قال انه الحق خسائر
فادحه بالقوات المسلحه الروسيه عند بلدتي
اعلنا المتحدث باسم المجموعه الجنوبيه
للقوات الروسيه انه تم صد اربع هجمات
جنتها مجموعه اوكرانيه على محور دونيت
كافيك لشوفكا ومارينكا
في تصريحات لسبوت ان الطيران الروسيه
والقوات الصاروخيه والمدفعيه استهدفت
منشات تابعه لعده الويه اوكرانيه كما تم
تدمير قطار يحمل اسلحه ومعدات عسكريه
اوكرانيه في منطقه قريه
ومستودعين للاسلحه
نشرت قنوات اعلاميه مقربه من الدفاع
الروسيه من وزاره الدفاع الروسيه مقطع
فيديو قالت انه يوثقه لحظه تدمير مقاتله
روسيه من طرازوخوي 35 طائره اوكرانيه في
مكان غير محدد واظهرت اللقطات المصوره
اقلاع المقاتل الروسيه وتحليقها في سماء
البلاد واطلاقها صاروخا في الجو دون ظهور
الطائره الاوكرانيه التي زعمت انها دمرتها